my you know what i was saying about
christmas i think you gave a good
example actually
uh would i want someone to see their
family of course that's what christmas
is about
whether people uh celebrate christmas as
a festival for themselves or from any
other
belief system it's a it's an opportunity
for families but
would i encourage someone to hug and
kiss their elderly relatives no i would
not
it's not against the law and that's the
whole point you can do it
within the rules that are there but it
does not make sense because you could be
carrying the virus and if you've got an
elderly relative
that would not be the thing you'd want
to do in the period where we're running
up to
a point where actually we might be able
to protect older people so i think
people just have to have sense and i
think this is
but this is very much what i think
people will do the fact that you can do
something this is true across so many
other areas of life
doesn't mean you should in answer to
your direct question about what i'll be
doing actually i'll be on the wards
i think keep numbers down don't do
things that are unnecessary as chris
said
try to make sure that you avoid
behaviors that would spread the disease
make sure that if you're in a house with
other households that you've got it well
ventilated and you take the precautions
keep distance where you can it's the
same basic rules that we need to apply
and i think you know it's difficult it's
not it's not going to be a normal
christmas but
if you want to make those connections
with family it has to be done in a way
where you try and make sure that you
don't increase the risk and as chris
said i think hugging elderly relatives
is not something to get
to to go out and do this it will
increase the spread to a vulnerable
population yeah you want to survive to
be
hugged again
you